we do have a guest we are with ashrida
eswaran after her second Victory
back-to-back victories he took down Anna
zatonski now abrahamian how do you feel
right now it feels really good Tatum has
been like a very problematic opponent
personally for me because I think we've
played like maybe nine ten times and I
don't really have a good record against
her
um so it's finally nice to win
especially with block against her and it
felt like you were so well prepared out
of this opening and thought of if I'm
not mistaken played something similar at
the American Cup against Alice Lee did
you prepare based on that game yeah I
did so actually it's my again my first
time playing this opening
um and I think we had a game in the
summer in July and I was black then too
and I played a terrible game so this
time I just I wanted to be more
aggressive and I think playing the
Sicilian was the way to go okay take us
through the opening phase this was the
first time you played this Russian Club
oh wow and
I was actually
clock I think I was I remember I knew
the position to like move 21 or
something like de3
um but yeah I saw that you know she
originally back in the days used to play
uh after instead of C4 after Bishop F6
Bishop F6 she used to play the C3 line
um all the way here yes yeah
um instead of C4 here yeah C3 yes so and
then recently especially her game
against Alice and then I think she had a
title Tuesday game over the summer as
well she started playing the C4 move
um
and I just so I was well prepared um and
I think she played the same plan with
Queen F3 G4 H4 so I was just looking at
this position and just got lucky that it
happened today
um but yeah she was spending a lot of
time
um did the rest day help with your
preparation you managed to check
everything all the possibilities it
definitely did but I didn't like
paired I did the normal preparation
because I also did have schoolwork to do
okay but yeah I was able to at least get
a little bit more than usual absolutely
so take us through the game after yeah
so here yeah after wreckage when I
looked at this bishop F7 and with this
idea of taking on H5
um and so you were still in your
preparation at this point well uh and so
I looked at night ce3 I just
um and I think I was planning to play
Bishop G6
Knight F5 and Bishop or not Bishop
Bishop B5 first yeah yeah Bishop G5
first yeah yeah Bishop G5 first Knight
F5 and Bishop G6 and this is a very
complicated position okay
but I thought I'd take my chances
especially since she was low on time
that was some Trend I saw like in her
previous games as well in this
tournament
um and I had the two Bishops and I felt
confident that you know there's a lot of
complications there and it felt like you
were also willingly putting a lot of
pressure on her time that was part of
the strategy as well I think last couple
of times I played her she managed her
time pretty well and so I felt like I
had to put the pressure on her from the
beginning of the game this time
absolutely and you played this more Ruto
D7 taking to h8 and yeah we were looking
at a position with the G file open
things were looking dangerous for you uh
were you concerned at all or I was
slightly concerned I think instead of uh
instead of C5 actually on move 26
um I thought Knight F5 was a possibility
because if I go Rook D7
um I thought my age four I'm not sure if
it works but Rook C7 and Knight G6 ideas
and I was worried about this
um but I so I suspected on Knight F5 I
had to give up the D6 Pawn like I did in
the game and go for counter play
um how would you do that that's a good
question
um I thought Bishop takes C4 Knight
something like this
um
there was it looked really hard though
if she played this way though Knight to
my five yeah that was the movie you were
concerned yeah that was definitely the
move I was concerned about
um and I think here yeah I think
um there were some lines where I wanted
to like even sack my queen I think
Bishop G8 was the move perhaps Bishop
yeah Knight F7 and then uh takes maybe
with a bishop yeah with the bishop and
then played this position because
um my Dark Sword Bishop is good and
she's still kid at Castle and you have
some Knight D4 coming in yeah yeah
definitely looks like some solid
compensation in this one and uh let's
take a look at what she played she
played this move C5 and after that it
felt like you are taking over I think
she missed the move B3 I I'm not so sure
but after B3 a B3 Bishop B3 I think she
was already thinking a lot and after run
D6 Queen B8
um she played Queen E2
um and here I was looking at incident
night before I think I was consider
considering like Bishop takes E3 or even
uh like just Queen yeah
and then I think still night before like
some ideas of picking up the pawn on C5
and playing on but I thought night
before
uh without trading a pair of minor
pieces was better and then here when she
played Rook B6 I played Knight C2 and I
think she realized she couldn't take
back on C2 because a queen takes B6 and
Rook C2 yes
um
which I think she might have missed
initially because she started thinking
like for a few minutes here and then
played King F1
um and then here again I was debating
whether to go like Knight takes E3 fe3
um
and I think Rook B7
um
but I again I thought she was getting
away with everything here
um and so I decided to play Queen E8 and
queen A4
um
yes
and then take on e4
um and and what if she goes something
like why do you want here Bishop uh yeah
I was gonna take on
five or Bishop C4 then take on C5 got it
it's just something like this yeah but
there's B3 I think maybe queen of three
maybe King G2 trying to run away this is
probably her best chance I think
um
and if you go d8 maybe something like D1
or
try to do something yeah along these
lines
cool and she played Knight takes E3 and
at this point you found this idea with
Queen to A2 Queen D3 Bishop E6 it
definitely got more messy than I
expected
um but I think she was just really low
on time but I felt like this should be
winning with F5 E4 ideas and her King is
under a lot of pressure here with the
two Bishops yep and it was indeed Queen
to D6 Rook to E8 she exchanged but you
gave her no chance I was I looked at I
think instead of I thought Rook A1 Rook
A4 was clever because if I take then uh
Queen takes E6 and she has chances there
because my king is weak oh she's Queen
f8 maybe some perpetuals but I think I
was lucky that E4 I had E4 there
um and you saw this from afar yeah yeah
I saw this when I played Queen C4 I was
debating whether I could go E4 when she
played Rook A1 but I figured to have my
queen closer to the king and bring it
back and then very nice very nice a nice
way to finish the game ashrita a very
aggressive game you must be feeling good
about let's say the bounce back
victories in the last couple of rounds
given how I started I think this is the
best possible possible way to move
again I'm just taking a
today was a very important game given
our history but also given the
tournament situation guys any questions
for us just our congratulations
congratulations Sharifah keep it up a
very very nice bounce back victories for
you
thank you indeed and sum it up or is